Europe has more than 13,000 kilometers
of external borders on land and nearly
66,000 kilometers at sea to strengthen
those borders Parliament is revising the
European border and Coastguard Agency
under the plans the agency will get a
new Corps of 10,000 staff by 2020 seven
agents will be tasked with policing
borders tackling organized crime at
managing migration we would like our
citizens to continue enjoying their
freedom of movement at the internal
borders we need it to secure the
external borders and this is what this
agency and this regulation aims to do in
the event of an emergency like the
migrant crisis of 2015 countries will be
able to call on its rapid intervention
force for assistance the changes will
see the introduction of fundamental
rights monitors to ensure the agency
respects human rights especially when
dealing with migrants or asylum seekers
you have to be fair with those who
deserve protection harsh with those who
are preying on the vulnerable and firm
with those who are seeking to to break
the rules when it comes to those who've
broken immigration rules the agency will
support EU governments identifying a
regular migrants obtaining necessary
travel documents and facilitating their
return
you